hello I'm Leah belletto and this is the
Sky News Daily and on this episode we're
talking about a massive leak of military
intelligence
classified U.S documents about the war
in Ukraine have been turning up on an
online gaming forum and the Pentagon has
hinted it's braced for more
they seem to show details about UK
forces operating in Ukraine the states
of Ukrainian air defenses and how the
U.S might monitor other countries
Communications with Russia and China
the accuracy of the files is being
questioned and the U.S have admitted
they're investigating the leak
our defense and security expert
Professor Michael Clarke will be here to
talk about what impact all of this could
be but first Jack Taylor works for the
Sky News data and forensics team a
Jack's job is all about verifying
information which turns up online
so what did you make of these leaked
documents when did you first see them so
it was about it was last Wednesday I
think the 5th of April when they first
started to appear online I came into the
office and the kind of Open Source areas
I monitor anyone could get into them
we're talking pages of telegram bits of
Twitter I look at it for my work as part
of monitoring for the Ukraine war
um I log in that morning and all I see
is sort of these pages of documents have
been taken and posted and then we'll
start us talking about wow there's these
leaked documents out there so that's the
first time I saw them so what did you
think and what did you take away from
what you did see the thing that got me
initially was that there was one page of
military losses that Russia and Ukraine
had both suffered but there were two
versions going around uh there was a
version that heard Ukrainian losses
starting at 16 000 but then there was
another version going through
pro-russian channels that had the
numbers changed to 61 000 so there was
these sort of one had been doctored
wasn't sure which but that was the thing
that kind of stuck into my mind along
with everything else and that's when you
start to think I wonder are they real
exactly have they been planted yeah what
did you do next so the thing I did next
in a bunch of Open Source research stood
next is you you want to when you find
something like this you want to find out
the original source of it
um with any piece of video or text that
Sky News uses part of my job is who
filmed it where is it who wrote this
sort of things you have to trace it back
so bellincat who are an open source
investigative unit uh um they do what I
do but long-term investigations also
Ukraine what they found was that some of
these documents had appeared actually a
month ago on a Discord which is sort of
a mess a gaming app sort of use it to
message your information as you're
working
um but the the documents that appeared
on servers on Discord dedicated to
Minecraft and YouTubers and it was kind
of in this context of like oh my god
look what I've gotten like people
showing off
um so they've been traced all the way
back there another Forum Pages like on
4chan another internet Forum website um
so they've been around for about a month
that we can tell from open source
research yeah and what can what can we
take away from them what do we know so
we don't know let's start that we don't
know who initially took the photos of
the documents because what people got to
remember is the photos of a page that's
been taken passed around so we don't
know who took those so that's the
question mark in my head so we know
where they've come from and kind of
where the spread has started from these
sort of servers we don't know who took
it and we don't know the context of why
they were taken or where they were sent
out but what we do know is that the
Pentagon are investigating the leak into
the documents but they themselves are
saying whilst we're investigating we
have to warn that we know that quite a
few of these have been altered and
doctored when you came across this
particular batch of documents that were
photographs alarm Bells must have been
ringing it must have been one of those
moments where you thought oh dear this
is quite big it could completely and I
think
for us in this one we can't verify the
contents of real so we're reliant on the
Pentagon saying they're investigating
we're relying on our knowledge of
Ukraine and what we're looking at you
know these are correct control maps of
the switch people might be familiar with
but if they're not it's the maps you'll
see on Sky News all the time that show
uh Ukraine with the lines of the front
line of the wall
um that's basically based on assessments
of current control by Russian and
Ukrainian forces using verified photos
and videos found online that's put
together by The Institute of the study
of wool so that was used in some of the
documents that we saw but I think as far
as our work went we had to step back and
go let's wait for the people to know
they're talking about to tell us what
these are because there's no way kind of
within my line of work that I can verify
the documents as they are so we've got
to take a step back and wait for the
authorities to talk about it
so how does the US deal with a high
security leak Michael Clarke is our
security and defense expert Michael
Clark great to see you again nice to be
here we're talking about leap documents
how does the Pentagon go about stopping
something like this happening in the
first place well what they have to do is
first of all as we insulate the damage
from these leaks then they have to try
to find out who did it though that might
not be so difficult in the present
circumstances but then they've got to
review their security policy and the
security policy has always been very odd
in this respect there are estimated to
be about 1.3 million people in America
who have access to secret and top secret
documents and the Americans have long
had a philosophy that they call Dare to
share you know we have a philosophy in
Britain of need to know do you need to
know it if you don't need to know it you
won't know it you won't get you don't
get the information but in the American
system it is dare to share which is to
get everybody on board with a common
picture of what we're talking about and
of course it's based on the idea that
proper Americans are patriotic enough
not to leak material or not to do
anything treacherous but if 1.3 million
people have got access to some form of
secret material then even a small
proportion you know 0.1 percent of those
people if they are Geeks Who want to be
a big shot amongst their friends as this
person probably did amongst his gaming
friends and I'm sure it is a hymn
um then you know some people like that
will emerge from the system this person
or or group of people I think are
computer geeks who put it on a gaming
site the Discord gaming site which is a
little site you know play for for the
playing of games amongst a pretty small
group of people and these documents seem
to have sat on the Discord site for many
days possibly weeks before anybody
worked out that they were quite
important documents because I found it
quite curious that it was this gaming
Forum that first landed these documents
or pictures of the documents but then
when we're talking about the context of
the war in Ukraine it's always been has
it Michael this disinformation war this
manipulation of information
do you think that plays in any aspects
of these documents or or a benefit to
Putin well in that way it might because
there's any number of conspiracy
theories out there which the Russians
are very anxious to Peddle and they
produce these conspiracy theories about
uh chemical weapons being developed in
Ukraine about Ukraine having a nuclear
program all completely ridiculous but if
any of these these crazy conspiracy
theories actually carry any weight with
some people and they do yeah then it's
possible that people even inside the
American system would think yeah the
Russians actually are on to they're on
to something here and we are behaving we
the Americans are not telling the truth
it's entirely possible that that
information War has had an effect on
somebody I mean again I think it's more
geeky than than treacherous but there
may be an element of treachery in this
because the information war is very
active at the moment and in the rest of
the world I have to say the Western
world is losing the argument over the
Ukraine war in the rest of the world the
global South more people are essentially
sympathetic to Russia
you know albeit 70 000 war crimes
married behavior and cutting the heads
off prisoners as they have as there is
evidence of it doesn't matter that a lot
of the world is is sympathetic to Russia
as if somehow the Western world needs a
good kicking needs to be pushed back
need to be shown who's boss and that's a
very disturbing development
well should we dig a little bit deeper
into these leaks then because one of
them focuses on Western special forces
in Ukraine what did you make of that
well um it would be surprising to me if
Western special forces were not
operating in Ukraine I have no idea if
these leaks are true yes and they gave
very precise numbers you know 50 British
Special Force operatives and uh you know
a few handfuls of of American French
there's one netherlander there Latvian
those numbers were suspiciously
um precise but
um I'd be surprised if there weren't
Special Forces operating from the West
because it's what they do the idea that
Britain would have more than others I
think is credible because British
Special Forces are renowned around the
world they are very very good and
they're very good for this sort of thing
which is not going around killing people
or fighting people they can do that if
they if they have to they can they can
visit paralyzing violence on the king's
enemies if necessary but their job what
makes them special is that they can
exist in any environment and they can
sit and they can watch and that's what
they do they don't need support they
don't need back one and two man squads
can exist in the mountains of
Afghanistan or the deserts of of Arabia
or the the Streets of London lying in a
doorway as if you were a drunk adult
homeless person
just watching what goes on really
counted her with a special
reconnaissance regiment yeah they
concentrate on counter-terrorism and
counter crime and some of their
reconnaissance goes on in London it's
not I'm not revealing anything record
it's now in the public record that at
least one of those operatives wrote his
own book about lying in a doorway
covered in drink wearing clothes that
he'd had for two or three weeks or the
resmelt
um and he was a down and out he was a
Dropout and his job was to hang around
in the doorway for a couple of weeks
observing what was going on in a certain
part of London so you would be surprised
I suppose if there wasn't special forces
in Ukraine that would be the surprise
yeah and the job in Ukraine almost
certainly if they are acting in Ukraine
and would be observation it's
reconnaissance they would just exist and
what information would be they be
extracting then well it might be a scale
of Russian forces I mean it might be
they might be looking at you know
numbers of Russian uh uh armaments going
westwards uh on on the railways or
convoys or trucks or they might have
been looking for headquarters points I
mean aiming points for Ukrainian
artillery in this situation it might
have been more second hand material just
just trying to observe where the Russian
forces were building up and where their
centers of power really were within any
given front that's would be my guess so
the ministry of Defense they've released
a statement
um what did you make of what they said
oh it's entirely sensible from their
point of view which is to say first of
all remember that there's a lot of
inaccuracies in these papers I mean the
Americans are pretty well admitted yes
that this leak is genuine but that
what's actually out there has been
doctored in some respects and we know
that is true and so the mod are using
that to say look
um you know don't believe what you read
in these papers even though I suspect
that 90 of them probably are true but
the 10 I guess have been doctored in
ways that we can see and the other thing
the mod is saying which is what they
always say perfectly sensible they say
we do not comment on Special Force
operations we neither confirm nor deny
we just don't talk about it and that's
fine that's that's what you'd expect
them to do so they don't get drawn into
discussions with people like me saying
well I think they're probably doing this
they're probably doing that no no mod
very sense we said look we don't talk
about it you say what you like about
them we don't talk what about Moscow
then what can we expect to hear from
Moscow well it will play into their
narrative and they'll say oh look these
papers prove that the West is actually
attacking us in Ukraine but they've been
saying that anyway and they certainly
won't be surprised I mean if I'm not
surprised that Western Special Forces
might be operating in Ukraine Moscow
certainly won't be surprised they would
have known it just as indeed I mean
their own special forces operate in
other parts of the world
um and of course in Ukraine so
um no surprises there but it will play
into the propaganda war that that Moscow
is conducting against the West saying
that this is not really about Ukraine
this war is all about the West's
determination to destroy Russia by
drawing us into a war in Ukraine that's
their current narrative well the other
documents seen actually by NBC he
suggestion you're Keen to get your
thoughts on this that the battle for
Ukraine's Eastern Don bass region is
most likely heading for a stalemate
through 2023
um does that tally up with what what
you've been seeing well we know that
yeah it does in a way not that that's
the truth but it is true that a lot of
people in the Pentagon including Mark
milley who's the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs
um I have expressed skepticism as to
whether the ukrainians are able to make
a decisive breakthrough and nobody knows
and so in saying that in these papers
they're only they're only really echoing
what Mark milley has implied in public
statements and what we know some people
in the Pentagon think and what it tells
us is there's a there's a big discussion
in the Pentagon they're looking at
Ukrainian capabilities they're looking
at the training they're they're looking
on paper what they've got to where the
Russians are and so on and they're
saying okay on a tabletop exercise can
they do it and the answer is well we'd
like to think so but we're not sure and
that the Ukraine is Main launched this
offensive it may run out of steam as all
offensives do eventually and that might
leave them just with another stalemate
and that would be very destabilizing
because even if they've taken more
territory if they haven't somehow broken
the the main part of Russia's grip on
the territory then the there will be a
sort of a fatigue building into the
Western World to say look this war is is
such a stalemate it's going to go on for
a long time the ukrainians can't really
win it on the battlefield therefore
we've got to look for a way out and
therefore Putin succeeds oh so this
spring offensive it's all or nothing
really I'm afraid it is yeah if it
leaves them in a state of stalemate then
it will be very hard to keep the
consensus going in the Western World to
keep on supplying Ukraine at these very
high levels both of equipment and you
know not to mention five billion dollars
a month
um to just to keep Ukrainian government
going so Michael your final thoughts
then on these lock leaks documents and
what it might mean for changes for the
U.S in the UK in terms of their strategy
if anything or is it kind of been blown
out of proportion what we've seen well
we should keep these things in
perspective every now and again there is
a sort of spy scandal in one of the the
five eyes countries you know sort of
Britain America Canada Australia New
Zealand those are the five eyes who are
the they are the best and biggest uh
intelligence collaboration in the world
and every now and again there's a spy
Scandal or a league Scandal and it it
destroys a certain amount of trust it
causes a certain amount of embarrassment
and bridges have to be rebuilt but they
always are and so I don't think we
should get this out of proportion this
is inconvenient it's bad for the Biden
Administration it will not play well in
Biden's re-election campaign because the
Republicans will keep bringing it up
even though it's got you know nothing to
do with Democrat Republican ideas
um and they will need to to rebuild a
bit their relationships with their
allies after this so they will put
together
um as it were a holding strategy over
these papers they'll get over it um and
there will be another such scandalous
spy Scandal or whatever it might be a
few years down the line that's in the
nature of intelligence relationship
[Music]
Taylor and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily this episode was produced
by Emma Ray Woodhouse and Alex edin the
editor is Paul stanworth
foreign
[Music]